that is a Friday in the classroom of
building 20 sucks and I will clock a.m.
I'm so I was part nervous first day is a
little bit nervous for me I was nervous
I'm not gonna deny it facing your
students for the first time can be a
little scary but it's also an
opportunity to establish that your class
will be user friendly I think the first
day of class really sets the tone for
the rest of the semester how can you set
the right tone as they make their way to
your classroom on the first day what
qualities are your students hoping for
you need to feel that you can approach
them and have just like an air of
confidence in being easy to understand
and being enthusiastic okay being there
having the presence having a lesson plan
ready and well organized that may sound
like a lot let's start with
approachability that is important you
feel accepted I'm welcomed in the
environment being approachable can be as
simple as facing the class and smiling
even if you feel like hiding behind your
papers and making eye contact making eye
contact just is a good personal
connection to the to a person who you're
talking to the artist in general so
students feel like the explanation
you're making is for them but it is an
important form of communication for them
to definitely holds the students
attention in terms of like international
cheese in general there may be some
misunderstanding here and there but I
think it's supported to make the
students comfortable asking for like
this for the th repeat like any word or
any sentence I think I think at the
beginning of the semester they should
maybe say that it's okay for the
students to ask for clarifications on if
something isn't clear I think that's
generally a good thing for all CSSA just
still welcome any question so that
you're open you care about the success
of the students that you are trying to
teach
enthusiasm is another way to show your
students your class will be friendly
being enthusiastic and showing that
you're actually passionate about the
material you're teaching that also gives
a little you know other more comfortable
atmosphere during recitation I think TAS
who are like exciting about what they
what they're teaching or if like what
they're teaching is like very specific
to their research you can tell that they
want to teach it and they want me to
learn it because they're very excited
about it and the student is probably
gonna be more engaged and before any
other quality students say they want
knowledge but they're also confident
you'll have it I think I personally
trust that um like MSE has selected fine
TAS the teachers of material so on the
first day rather than trying to impress
the students stick with the simple
explanation of why you are a good fit to
teach the class I'm a third-year quite a
student in the Department of CCS I'm
working with Professor Albin town who is
also the lecturer of this class students
also want TAS to show self-confidence I
think your confidence in see I think of
someone who is very they come off as
like okay like I know this material
later than you and I'm gonna teach it to
you so often I think TAS who speak not
super fast and just like pretty
articulate and slower so that their
point gets across usually um I feel more
sure that they're pretty better pretty
good at explaining things to speed you
have when you're talking to conversation
just like divide that by two and just
because you're nervous in front of
people that's people like increase it
either way so speaking a little bit more
slowly helps a lot because you can also
have the time to think about what you're
saying
and the audience in the students you're
speaking to will have a better time
understanding especially if the
pronunciation or if you have a certain
accent so speed makes a difference in
how students see you what about volume
in a big classroom I definitely have to
remind myself that I have to raise my
voice of a bit louder speaking too
quietly can also give the impression of
nervous
swigs actually focuses on setting greed
conversion a stronger voice projects
confidence and commands attention this
week's lecture focuses on sampling rate
conversion getting to the classroom
early can also help you to feel more
confident because you can get to know
the students before you start teaching
and planning ahead not only makes you
feel more confident it also makes
students confident in you so I think one
ta that I had when I think of a user
friendly class I think of his class
because he every day he had his
recitation planned to a minion which was
pretty ridiculous but it actually was
very logical in a way that helped the
students learn so he would pretty much
write the agenda on the on the
blackboard like from minute zero to
minute five like we're too close I'm for
a minute five to ten we were talking
about the if they're if they seem like
they're well organized like they have
their papers and like a nice little
folder I definitely look at that and
having having a real lesson plan is
showing that there's going to be like
productivity and the recitations is
important having some of your paired
shows that they were like thinking about
us when we were in class finally
international teaching assistants also
stressed preparation and planning in
their advice for a successful first day
as an international teaching assistant
we we have some disadvantages probably
compared to native speakers but if you
are if we are prepared if we show our
enthusiasm towards the substrate I think
the students will feel them as well
just be prepared that's that's what this
week's scores about you you're very
prepared I went through all the notes
all the books that are related to the
course and I tried to prepare some with
examples I think for that class I did a
over preparation that if I discuss
everything on my notebook it would take
two hours instead of one hour so I think
never running out of material
Sims another source of my confidence I
should be confident enough to food just
by the sake of being the TA nothing
she'd ever be nervous because you do
know more about the topic that they do
um it was Tanjung but in a good way and
everything prepared do your best
you